the left when it comes to abortion they
prefer to talk about the hard cases they
prefer to talk about rape and incest
they want this entire discussion to be
centered around far less than one
percent of all abortions uh they also
prefer to talk about abortions very
early on in pregnancy but the truth is
that anyone who is pro-abortion or
quote-unquote pro-choice it means that
they support abortion through all phases
of pregnancy the way that they dress it
up is by is this whole bit about it's
only to save the life of the mother that
is a fantasy that category of abortion
does not exist it is never necessary to
have an abortion in the third trimester
of pregnancy or at any trimester to have
a late term abortion to save the life of
a mother never there are certainly
things that can happen in a pregnancy
where a woman's life is in jeopardy and
it means that the pregnancy has to be
ended but there is only one way to do it
and that is to deliver the baby the
question is whether you kill the baby
before delivering him that's an extra
step there is no medical reason to do